Entschuldigung.
Bitte schön.
Guten Abend.
Mein Name ist Frau Schäker.
Ich bin hier als Assistentin tätig.
Heute möchte ich mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch durchführen.
Sind Sie einverstanden?
Ja, hallo. Guten Abend.
Wie ist Ihr Name nochmal, bitte?
Mein Name ist Schäker.
Schäker. Was ist das für ein Name?
Schäker ist eine türkische Nachname.
Ich komme aus der Türkei.
Ach so.
Okay, herzlich willkommen. Guten Abend.
Danke schön.
Bevor wir anfangen, muss ich schnell ein paar persönliche Fragen stellen.
Wie heißen Sie?
Mein Name ist Melanie Kant.
Frau Kant, könnten Sie Ihre Formen machen, mal langsam, büchtig?
Melanie, Martha, Emil, Ludwig, Anton,
Nordpol, Ida, Emil, Karl-Anton, Nordpol, Theodor.
Okay.
Frau, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 46 Jahre alt.
46. Okay.
Und wann genau sind Sie geboren?
Am 23. März, 1978.
Und wie groß sind Sie?
Frau Doktor, ich komme hier, weil ich Beschwerden habe.
Sie fragen nach meiner Größe. Ich verstehe das nicht.
Ja, ich verstehe, aber ich muss diese Fragen stellen,
um zum Beispiel Medikamente-Dosis zu berechnen.
Okay, ich bin, ich glaube, 1 Meter 65.
Sie wollen sicherlich auch mein Gewicht wissen.
Könnten Sie wiederholen?
Sie wollen wahrscheinlich auch mein Gewicht wissen.
Ja.
Ich bin 72 Kilo.
71. Okay.
Gut.
Frau Kant, was führt Sie so uns?
Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Frau Doktor, ich habe seit heute Mittag starke Schmerzen
auf der rechten Seite vom Bau.
Oder unter der Bereich?
Das ist schwer zu starten.
Es ist mehr im Unterbereich, im Unterbau.
Und es strahlt so ein bisschen in meine Leiste,
als im Unterbau.
Es strahlt von der rechten Seite in den Mittelbauch,
in die Mitte.
Es sind zum Teil Krämpfe, manchmal sind es Schmerzen.
Ich weiß nicht, wie ich es beschreiben soll.
Einfach ganz komisch, aber sehr, sehr schmerzhaft.
Es nimmt immer zu.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Haben diese Schmerzen plötzlich begonnen oder eher langsam?
Ich würde sagen eher plötzlich.
Also, das fing heute Mittag an, vorher hatte ich gar nichts.
Jetzt ist es richtig schlimm geworden,
sodass ich herkommen musste.
Gibt es bestimmte Auslöse?
Haben Sie bemerkt zum Beispiel Essen?
Nein, das kann ich nicht sagen.
Das fing heute Mittag an.
Ich habe auch nichts Besonderes gemacht.
Ich war zu Hause, habe nur ein Buch gelesen,
und dann fing das an.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Kennen Sie diese Schmerzen?
Hatten Sie früher schon einmal?
Nein, überhaupt nicht.
Das erste Mal, dass ich solche starken Schmerzen habe.
Könnten Sie die Schmerzen genauer beschreiben?
Sie haben schon krampfig gesagt, aber zum Beispiel Brennen,
oder?
Also, Brennen nicht, aber zum Teil sticht das.
Das ist richtig.
Der strahlt so ein bisschen in den Unterbauch aus,
in die Mitte.
Ich habe auch eine leichte Übelkeit, seitdem merke ich jetzt.
Kannst du sie sich übergeben?
Nein, das noch nicht, aber die Übelkeiten nehmen zu.
Zum Teil sind die Schmerzen auch so ein bisschen krampfartig.
Einmal mehr, mal weniger.
Also sehr unangenehm.
Ja, okay.
Wie würden Sie die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzzucker,
von 1 bis 10, wenn 1 leichte Schmerzen und 10
starkeste Schmerzen bedeutet?
Ich würde sagen, es hat mit 2, 3 angefangen,
ist jetzt bei 5 oder 6 oder sogar mehr.
Okay.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Nein, das bin ich aufgefangen.
Ich habe jetzt noch nicht Fieber.
Leiden Sie unter Kalschweiß oder schwitzen Sie so viel?
Schwitzen? Nein, an sich auch nicht.
Es sind nur die Schmerzen.
Okay.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Sturrgang oder Wasserlassen?
Das nicht, aber ich habe das Gefühl,
mein Bauch ist ein bisschen aufgebläht.
Ich habe das Gefühl, der Bauch ist richtig dick.
Ich möchte auf Toilette, aber da kommt nichts.
Okay.
Wann war Ihre letzte Sturrgang?
Heute Morgen.
Heute Morgen, okay.
Okay.
Wie ist Ihre Appetit?
Also bis heute Mittag war das ganz gut,
aber heute Mittag habe ich keinen so richtigen Appetit.
Nein, ich habe auch nichts gegessen.
Ich habe noch ein bisschen was getrunken.
Ich habe auch schon mal eine Schmerztablette genommen,
aber das hat nicht viel geholfen.
Okay.
Was haben Sie eingenommen?
Ich habe zu Hause Paracetamol gehabt.
Eine Paracetamol habe ich genommen.
Kennen Sie die Dosis?
500 mg?
Weiß ich jetzt nicht.
Paracetamol war das.
Okay.
Nur eine Tablette, oder?
Ja, nur eine Tablette.
Ich mag keine Tabletten.
Aber das hat mir nicht viel gebracht.
Ach, okay.
Es hat nicht geholfen?
Nein, nein.
Ja, Frau Kant,
könnte es sein,
dass die Schwanger sein
ist, oder dass sie ihre letzte Diode haben.
Nein, das kann nicht sein.
Ich bin seit vier Jahren in der Minnepause.
Okay.
Das wäre zu schön.
Ich habe schon zwei Kinder.
Nein, nein, nein, vielen Dank.
Das ist noch nicht so.
Aber besuchen Sie Ihre Frauenarzt regelmäßig?
Ja, ja, ich bin normalerweise einmal im Jahr bei Frauenarzt.
Ja.
Wir fragen, um sie herzusein,
haben Sie keine Probleme beim Wasserlassen?
Ja.
Nein, Wasserlassen war in Ordnung.
Okay, gut.
Okay.
Frau Kant,
möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen über Ihre Beschwerden?
Nein, ich mache mir Sorgen,
dass es immer schlimmer wird.
Deswegen bin ich jetzt hierhergekommen.
Ich hoffe, dass es jetzt nicht schlimm ist.
Ja, okay. Ich verstehe.
Und ich mache sehr schnell.
Okay, aber ich möchte über
Sie überfolgen
etwas Fragen.
Leiden Sie an chronische Erkrankungen?
Wie zum Beispiel Blutzuckerkrankheit
oder Bluthochdruck?
Nein, nein, nein.
Bisher habe ich nichts gehabt.
Ja, gut.
Ich bin auch regelmäßig bei meinem Hausarzt.
Der kontrolliert auch immer wieder
meine Werte, also Laborwerte.
Er meinte, das ist bisher alles gut.
Okay, sehr gut.
Und nehmen Sie Ihre Gelb-Neistik
bei Bedarf Medikamente ein?
Nein.
Wie gesagt, ich mag keine Tabletten.
Manchmal will ich mal
Merzen habe, nehme ich ab und zu mal
Paracetamola, aber ansonsten
nehme ich keine Tabletten.
Okay. Wurden Sie
schon einmal operiert?
Ja,
so eine kleine OP
an der Gebärmutter, aber das war jetzt nichts Besonderes.
Was war das?
Das war ein Myom.
Ah, Myom, okay.
Okay.
Und wann war das?
Das war vor ungefähr fünf Jahren.
Aber es war alles in Ordnung.
Das war keine Komplikation.
Ja.
Frau Kond, ich möchte
mal eine Frage stellen.
Schlafen Sie gut?
Haben Sie ein oder andere Schlafstörungen?
Also mit dem Schlafen habe ich glücklicherweise
bisher keine Probleme.
Gut, okay.
Das ist in Ordnung.
Okay.
Und haben Sie allergien oder
Unverträglichkeiten?
Ja, also ich habe
zum einen Hausstauballergie
dann auch
gegen
gewisse Pollen und Gräser
und
Pollen und was?
Gräser.
Das ist Gras.
Ah, ja, Gras, okay.
Und
manchmal Medikamente kann ich nicht nehmen.
Ich habe mich sehr allergisch.
Was ist mit dem Schlafen?
Das Schmerzmedikament mit Novalgin.
Ah, okay.
Da habe ich einmal so ganz
schlimmen Ausschlag gehabt.
Deswegen
darf ich das nicht nehmen.
Aha.
Diese Information ist sehr wichtig für uns.
Okay.
Und ein Zibiotikum.
Ich glaube, das nannte sich Zipro
oder so ähnlich. Das vertrage ich auch nicht.
Zipro.
Wie reagieren Sie auf Zipro?
Ich kriege massiven Durchfall.
Ich kriege hier Lucreids.
Ich verstehe.
Das ist wichtig.
Okay.
Frau, kommt rauchen Sie?
Ja.
Okay.
Wie viele Geräte rauchen Sie täglich und seit wann?
Also ich rauche seit
20 Jahren.
Früher habe ich sehr viel geraucht.
Also fast eine ganze Schachtel am Tag.
Ich habe auch einen stressigen Job.
Wissen Sie?
Aber jetzt ist es deutlich weniger.
Ich hoffe nur die Hälfte
von der Packung.
Seit wann rauchen Sie eine halbe Packung?
Seit 2 Jahren ungefähr.
Okay.
2 Jahren haben Sie ein Schachtel geraucht.
Aber seit 2 Jahren
rauchen Sie nur eine halbe Packung.
Ja.
Okay, gut. Und trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, gelegentlich schon.
Was genau trinken Sie und wie oft?
Als ich mag,
gern Wein.
Aber das war es eigentlich.
Was anderes selten.
Zum Beispiel
viel, viel lesser Pro Woche.
Ich würde mal sagen,
1-2 Gläser.
Ja, nicht mehr.
Okay.
Ich habe noch ein paar Gläser.
Die letzte Frage
ist eine Routine Frage, Frau Kont.
Bitte nehmen Sie nicht persönlich.
Aber nehmen Sie Drogen oder haben Sie Erfahrung?
So Drogen?
Nein, nein, nein.
Ich habe Angst.
Frau Kont, jetzt würde ich Sie
nach Ihrer Familie gestätzt.
Was fragen Sie? Leiden Ihre Eltern
an chronische Erkrankungen?
Also, mein Vater
hat einen hohen Blutdruck.
weiß ich und meine Mutter, die hatte mal so Darmprobleme, aber im Moment geht es so gut.
Ich wüsste jetzt nicht, was sie noch haben.
Aber welche Darmprobleme haben sie nicht?
Ah, das weiß ich jetzt nicht, ehrlich gesagt.
Haben sie Geschwister?
Nein.
Okay.
Sind sie verheiratet, Frau kommt?
Ja, ja.
Und Sie haben zwei Kinder?
Ja.
Sie sind gesund?
Ja, ja.
Kinder sind gesund, beide studieren.
Also, das ist, da bin ich froh, ja.
Okay.
Und was machen Sie überflieglich?
Ich bin Projektmanagerin und ich arbeite in einer Logistikfirma.
Was haben Sie heute Mittag gegessen?
Auch nichts Besonderes, also das war ein kleines Salat.
Und eine kleine Suppe dazu.
Also das war jetzt nichts Besonderes.
Könnte es sein, das Essen verdorben lassen?
Nein, also das war ein frischer Salat, das habe ich selber gemacht.
Okay.
Ja, okay, Frau kommt.
Ich bin mit meinen Fragen fertig.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen oder etwas fragen?
Geben Sie etwas gegen die Schmerzen?
Also das kommt jetzt wieder, das ist so richtig, oh ihr Koligartig.
Macht keine.
Nein, das macht echt Schmerzen.
Kann ich etwas gegen die Schmerzen haben?
Ja, das ist jetzt schlimm.
Ja, ich verstehe.
Okay.
Jetzt ist so für die Undiagnose zu stellen, aber ich werde so erst Sie köpfeilig untersuchen.
Nach der Köpfeilig-Untersuchung kann ich gerne eine Schmerzmittel geben und fühlen Sie sich besser.
Können Sie nicht jetzt schon etwas geben, das wird echt schlimm.
Ja, aber es wäre besser für die Diagnose ohne Schmerzmittel-Untersuchung.
Oh je, ich herrschte, ich kann maus, das wird echt schlimmer jetzt.
Okay, könnten Sie nicht aufhalten?
Es wäre mir lieber, wenn ich etwas gegen die Schmerzen bekomme, bitte.
Okay, okay.
Dann können wir machen, aber ja okay, werden Sie nichts mehr aushalten.
Ja, das wäre mir sehr lieb. Vielleicht geben Sie mir am besten eine Spritze oder so.
Okay, wir können meine Infizierung begonnen, dann ja.
Aber bitte keine, bitte keine Novalgien, ja?
Ja, ja, natürlich.
Natürlich, ich achte die Medikamente auf der Medikamente, okay.
Wunderbar, hoffe, dass es wirkt, ja.
Haben Kollegen oder Kolleginnen noch eine Frage?
Ja, eine Frage.
Bitte schön.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit Apotheos zugenommen?
Nein, das Gewicht ist stabil.
Okay, danke.
Ich habe auch eine Frage. Waren Sie in der letzten Zeit auf einer Reise?
Nein, nein, nein. Die letzte Reise liegt schon länger zurück, so circa drei Jahre.
Verstehe, okay.
Keine Fragen?
Nach der Schmerzen gehen Wind ab?
Ja, die Winde gehen ab.
Guten Tag.
Abum Kollegen noch eine Frage.
Können wir als erstes Gecipri anfangen, Herr?
Ja.
Ich bin da.
Ja, die Hummus ist nicht mehr da.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Okay.
Guten Abend herhobere.
My name is Hafsuno Sheker, ich komme aus der Türkei und
bin 27 Jahre alt.
Ich habe an der Istanbul University Medicine Faculty 2021
abgeschlossen.
Nach der Abschluss habe ich zwei Jahre lang in Istanbul in der
Notfallmedizin gehört.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Ich habe zwei Jahre lang in Istanbul in der Notfallmedizin
gearbeitet.
Sehr gut.
Seit ungefähr sieben Monaten bin ich in Deutschland.
Hier habe ich drei Monate lang einen Deutschkurs gemacht
und ein Monat eine Hospitalität absolviert.
Momentan lerne ich für die Vollsprachürupung.
Sie sprechen dafür sehr gut, dass sie erst seit drei Monaten
lernen.
Aber in der Türkei habe ich zwei Jahre lang Deutschkurs gemacht.
Das merkt man.
Ja, gut.
Dann freut mich das, dass Sie bei uns arbeiten.
Ich glaube, Sie haben einen Patienten aufgenommen.
Dann stellen Sie mal vor, was ist mit der Patientin?
Okay.
Unsere Patientin heißt Melanie Kund.
Frau Kund ist 46 Jahre alt, 1,65 m groß, 72 kg schwer.
Frau Kund kann uns bewegen.
Seit heute Mittag bestehende, plötzlich akute, aufgetretene
Rechte unter Abdominalschmerzen, die Schmerzen würden
in Mittellbau ausgestrahlen.
Und die Patientin beschreibt die Schmerzen als krampfartig
und ehemaligerstährend.
Im Laufe Mittelszeit seien die Schmerzen Schlimmerke geworden.
Sie haben sich prognetiert.
Die Patientin, die Schmerzintensität, liegt auf einer Schmerzzikale.
Am Anfang, zwei bis drei, aber momentan bis sechs.
Sie haben diese Schmerzen erst einmal, früher hatte sie nicht.
Und als Begleitzymptome klackte sie über Nausea ohne Emesis.
Und sie haben eine Präsentomol, Tablet und klare Dosis eingenommen,
aber ohne Besserung.
Sie haben heute Mittag nicht besonderes gegessen.
Und letzte Stuhl war heute Morgen.
Sie knackte überall so setzlich Meteroismus oder Fröhliche.
Und sie hatte auch Schmerzbedingte in Appetenz.
Und sie seit vier Jahren in der Männerpause,
besuche ihren Frauen erst regelmäßig.
Und eine gynecologische Anamnese ist unauffällig.
Sie haben keine chronische Erkrankung und nehmen keine Medikamente regelmäßig ein.
An Veröparationen ist Utterismium Entfernung bekannt vor fünf Jahren.
Hat sie doch eine gynecologische Vorgeschichte?
Ja, genau.
Sie haben eine EU-OP.
Die EU-OP ist bekannt, aber keine Komplikation.
Sie haben Hausstab, Polen und Gräcia allergie.
Gräcia allergie, nicht Gräcia, sondern Gräcia.
Diese Wort ist neu für mich.
Sie haben sozusagen Neuergie und Siproallergie.
Sie haben Neuergie, die sich mit Exantem äußert.
Sie haben Siproallergie, die sich mit Diore und Puritus äußert.
Sie ist Raucherin.
Seit zwei Jahren rauche sie täglich halbe Paket.
Aber früher haben sie seit 20 Jahren einen Schatten geraucht.
Sie trinken ein bis zwei Gläser Weinprobe und Drogenkonsum für den Vernein.
Bei der Familie Anamnesi ergab sie Folgendes.
Ihr Vater leidet an Arterelle Hypertonie und ihre Mutter leidet an unbekannte Probleme.
Unsere Patiaten weiß es nicht.
Sie sei Einzelkind und sie sei verheiratet für zwei gesunde Erwachsene Kinder.
Und sie ist Projektmanagerin von Beruf.
Haben Sie schon einige Untersuchungen gemacht?
Nein, ich habe keine Untersuchungen gemacht.
Aber ich plane, so würde ich meine Patientin körperlich untersuchen,
kontrollieren und EKG schreiben und natürlich Blut abnehmen.
Für Labo kontrolliere ich Blutbildentzündung, Parameter WCRP und PSG.
Und Leberwerte und Nierenwerte.
Ja, genau.
Ich schag Ihnen jetzt die Ergebnisse der Laborwerte. Sie haben Blut abgenommen.
Das Blutbild zeigt eine Leukozytose von 13.000, ein CRP von 130.
Leberwerte sind in Ordnung, Nierenwerte sind in Ordnung.
Der Urin ist auch in Ordnung, keine Auffälligkeit.
Und Schilddröse ist auch in Ordnung.
Im Ultraschall sieht man viel Luft und fragliche Flüssigkeit im rechten Unterbau.
Kannst du sie wieder in der Hunde?
Ja, meine Verdacht, die hat noch sehr lautet, apotheapandisitis.
Die Entzündung, Parameter sind erhöht und Freiflassigkeit.
Woher denken Sie noch? Was kann es noch sein?
Es könnte eine Atnexitis.
Ein Endküpp des Eingersturbs.
Ein Handwerkingfekt.
Eine Handwerkinginfektion.
Ja, und Urulitis.
Ein Handleiterstein.
Woran denken Sie noch?
Eine Divertokulitis auf der rechten Seite.
Unwahrscheinlich.
Apothezitis haben wir schon.
Eine Perforation, freie Flüssigkeit.
Woran denken Sie noch? Peritonitis?
Ja, es könnte sein.
Eine Peritonitis, jawohl.
Differenzial diagnostisch müssen Sie noch auch eine Coalizistitis denken.
Auch wenn die Werte in Ordnung sind, die Labor- oder die Leberwerte.
Variatorsion.
Variatorsion, genau.
Kann auch mal sein.
Wenn Sie nicht in der Menepause sind, können wir extraviter in Gravidate denken, aber nicht.
Ist eher unwahrscheinlich, genau.
Man kann auch mal einen Bridenelius denken.
Verklebungen im Unterbau.
Was gibt es noch für Möglichkeiten?
Akute Gastroenteritis, vielleicht.
Akute Gastroenteritis, klar, muss man immer daran denken, das ist richtig.
Sehr gut, haben andere Kollegen noch andere Ideen?
Keine Ideen.
Gut, dann war es das erst mal.
Wunderbar, vielen Dank.
Es war gut, also ich würde auch sagen, das ist eher eine akute Appendicitis.
Mit Verdacht auf Perforation.
Was machen Sie mit der Patientin?
Wie bitte?
Was machen Sie mit dieser Patientin jetzt?
Ich mache sofort chirurgisches Konzil.
Also Sie stellen die Patientin bei den Chirurgen vor, genau.
Ja, und ich nehme die Patientin stationär.
Genau, also die Patientin muss relativ schnell operiert werden.
Sehr gut.
Können Sie laparoscopicia appendectomy aufklären?
Aufklären?
Ja, aber die Aufklärung ist die aufkabelische Rourke.
Nicht die Notfallerzten.
In der FSB ist unsere Aufklärung.
Echt?
Das wusste ich nicht.
Das wusste ich nicht auch.
Leider.
Haben Kollegen noch andere Fragen oder möchten Sie Kommentare?
Abgeben.
Also Dr. Gündes, also ihr Deutsch.